je voudrais avec le ministre
qui m'accompagne remercier très
chaleureusement les sapeurs-pompiers qui
sont intervenus en 12 minutes à 3h du
matin et on puisse sauver 15 personnes
en prenant des risques considérables
pour leur propre vie en escaladant
l'immeuble de l'extérieur puisqu'on ne
pouvait pas rentrer par l'intérieur et
en sauvant jusqu'au 7e étage des enfants
des bébés et donc sans la rapidité des
sapeurs-pompiers et sans leur héroïsme
il y aurait eu un bilan encore plus
dramatique et la priorité est d'une part
à l'identification des victimes nous
n'avons pas encore identifié toutes ces
personnes il y a notamment cinq enfants
entre 3 et 15 ans elle peut prendre
plusieurs heures ses identifications et
donner une réponse aux familles que nous
avons rencontrées qui sont évidemment
dans dans dans l'émotion parfois la
colère ce qui est évidemment tout à fait
légitime les familles
ont évoqué évidemment les points de Deal
qu'il y avait chacun le sait dans dans
cette rue particulière la police le sait
bien et à la demande même le maire
d'ailleurs les effectifs ces dernières
ont été très largement renforcés
quasiment policiers supplémentaires
qu'on procéder depuis le 1er janvier à
25 interpellations pour trafic de drogue
dans cette rue et dans ce numéro aussi
le numéro 12 il y avait un trafic de
drogue connu pour lequel évidemment les
scies enquêteurs avaient d'ailleurs
interpellé cette nuit même des
trafiquants le travail est très
important que nous faisons voler contre
la drogue peut-être une des réponses de
la situation et on ne veut privilégier
aucune d'entre elles mais il est sûr que
les familles nous ont évoqué ce point de
Deal et donc indirectement de squats
bien évidemment mais encore une fois il
est beaucoup trop tôt pour en tirer des
conclusions il s'agit d'une copropriété
dans lequel des travaux d'urgence
avaient été réalisés en 2019
donc c'est un quartier en renouvellement
urbain dans lequel la ville l'état la
métropole investit depuis de nombreuses
années
il s'agit d'un drame un drame absolu
insupportable parce qu'il y a des
victimes des morts des enfants qui qui
sont morts mais on peut pas incriminer à
ce stade l'état d'immeuble
[Musique]